last year i was reunited with someone
very special
the wonderful tom green
we were married and
it was just so wonderful
to reconnect with him and people thought
that we were really together but the
truth was he was 3 000 miles away in los
angeles
um to be safe for covid
and we used our phenomenal green screen
technology that i am so proud of um
because it is so good and seamless
but it leads to probably people not
realizing that we have not seen each
other face to face
actually in almost 20 years
but he's here
so
i am so excited ladies and gentlemen
please welcome comedian adventurer
pioneer and someone so dear to me tom
green
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for having me on the show it's
great to be here smells so minty fresh
oh yeah okay well yeah i took a mint
right before i came out
i just ate like cucumbers and celery
with some really weird sauce oh okay
yeah i wasn't gonna say anything
yeah okay to be here congratulations on
your show this is this is much nicer
than the uh the green screen by the way
i like this in person i can't wait to
talk to you about all the things that
you've done in the last year
um and they actually coincide with some
of our headlines today so i was
wondering will you join me at the news
desk really yes drew's news yes okay
okay okay great
all right well it's that time for drew's
news your spooky little news cauldron
bubbling over with green good news goo
and today
this news witch is joined by two news
wizards the magical tom green
and the mystical rusty russ matthews
[Applause]
i know
but it's my first one
i'm sorry you know you were not there at
the time
but we're here now absolutely well tom
the last time you spoke you were on this
incredible year-long road trip journey
when you kicked it off we talked about
um you were inspired by books like into
the wild
right yeah
travels with charlie as well by seinbeck
which is why i named my doggy charlie
right oh
did you
learn anything do you have any takeaways
well it was i was i was surprised that i
actually got so comfortable being alone
for so long you know like in the van in
the desert in these remote places just
charlie and i against the world and i
thought maybe you know this was going to
get a little lonely but with social
media it's interesting we'd go on live
and do these streams and
it actually ended up being really kind
of a nice
thing you know i i ended up kind of
really enjoying being out there in
nature
so it was nice it was kind of a fun
thing well i think people talk about
things and you actually did it i'm
impressed and in your honor our first
story today is about some kindred
spirits of yours a couple of road
trippers from the uk
fox news reports that shannon orr and
ian cameron drove across scotland's
north coast not by van not by rv
but by hearse
nice i converted hearse they called the
grim sleeper
it's got a bed in the back plenty of
room for their pups billy and peanut
maybe charlie couldn't hang out tom is
this a vehicle to die for or what sounds
good sounds good lots of space lots of
space it's made for lying down
for long periods of time right ross
could you
ride around in a hurry not for a single
moment thank you very much no i mean
it could be a killer ride but it's not
for me i'm i'm made for a winnebago this
is a winnipeg no
never
i don't i mean good for people for being
having ingenuity but uh enjoy your ride
bye
are you would you sounds fun to me i
think you get to hang out with some
ghosts yeah right
camping with ghosts would you really do
it
uh
probably not
i wouldn't think twice about it i think
superstition is totally what you believe
and you have the ability to cut off that
belief at any time remember the road
trip that we took um through ireland yes
absolutely yeah remember we for some
reason decided to hike up to the top of
a mountain we hiked up this crazy
mountain for hours hours and we just
were determined to reach the top but at
certain points i don't think we thought
we ever were going to i remember a
couple of things i think we might have
hiked up two mountains i remember one
mountain we got to the top it was foggy
and there was a sheep up there that
hadn't been shorn in years and it looked
like it was at a
and headstones it was there was a little
there was like a
it was a mini cemetery yeah absolutely
and then a storm came in yeah we had to
run down the mountain yes yes but we
like just jumped in random oceans and
found random fields it was it was a nice
trip it was like one of my favorite
trips of my life that was our honeymoon
it was our honeymoon by the way and it
was a good one yeah
[Applause]
we're all sitting here watching this
right we're all here this is happening
right and it feels so surreal what does
it feel like almost 20 years later to be
face to face what is it like
i kind of feel like i'm watching this
too right now
i don't know if that's weird it's sort
of a little bit like an out of body
experience i have a sort of uh it it's
very nice to see you it's really it does
feel weird though it does not weird in a
bad way weird in a good way yeah
appreciate it drew thanks for uh thanks
for having me on the show it's awesome
this is this is this is cool this is i
mean i actually think this is kind of a
a nice way of reconnecting actually
takes a little bit of the pressure off
well i respect and love you oh thank you
drew love you love you
this i have to say
this is my favorite show i could watch
this show all day long
first of all ross ross and i share
something in common we were both on
celebrity big brother uh yes we were and
we were both uh voted america's favorite
houseguest
yeah so yeah
yeah so this is the second weirdest tv
moment absolutely
[Music]
you